audio is live
videos live and then
howdy good morning rob jolly
soy boy always late remember this of
solely i mean that's what they're saying
what's going on here el de boss and then
we're
live we are officially live episode
number is this
16th episode that we have and we have
our good friend daniel de martino booth
here with us
morning to give us an update on what's
going on with the economy the new
stimulus that they're going back in for
pelosi trump all those guys and then
we got adam here as well the man the
mint the legend
soy boy which i saw a shirt that was
sent here i thought it was very
appropriate somebody wanted to send you
a shirt that says
i'll take to get each other i'll take it
okay so uh uh i think it's fair to say
today is the first day of q4
you kind of told us about at the
beginning which is true and there's a
lot of things going on they want to
change the format of the debate
we got a lot of topics we got some
economy topics that we're talking about
30 000 airline jobs maybe even 50 000 at
this point
that uh are out there that may be lost
you got palantirs officially public
company
harley davidson is leaving india the
world's largest
motorcycle market leaving india
a bunch of layoffs kpmg allstate golden
uh goldman sachs disney's letting go of
28 000 jp morgan's 980
20 million dollar fine for market
manipulation spoofing
64 of people say the economy worse than
it was a year ago
china's k-shaped economy and changing in
the debate format and a bunch of other
topics
a lot of things to cover here but before
we get into the topics
daniel since we have you here we've
already responded to the debate
on what took place between biden and
trump i want to kind of get your
thoughts here how
what did you think of that wonderful you
know easy going
you know debate that took place a few
days ago well see i'm one of these geeky
types i actually
wanted to know what policies they were
prescribing
for the country remember that 64 who
think the economy is worse
i didn't hear much in terms of substance
i didn't so i was kind of disappointed
there
i mean you couldn't hear anything you
didn't see substance you couldn't hear
anything no
it was a it was a it was a cluster-ish
thing
mr ish did you think one did better than
the other like meaning you know trump
came in did you think trump did better
than you thought he was going to do or
did you think biden did better than he
thought he was you thought he was going
to do
oh i think the consensus is that biden
didn't mess up
okay i think i think that that is there
there was this concern
that there was going to be some major
gaffe on stage and
i mean he he kind of held his own in the
boxing ring
you think so i think he did what's your
football score between the two guys
what is the football score you know
right now i think we're we're tied at
the half
really you're just putting it a tie
right now oh that's that's where
vegas has been pretty neck and neck and
i i go with vegas here's here's a
question for you you're not they do
these vp pres i know you i know you're
you're a pence fan do you think the vp
debates matter at all
i think have you seen the demographics
of the presidential candidates
yes they matter i mean more than ever
before
meaning like if there's ever been a time
that it matters more would you say
well one of them has got cholesterol
issues the other one who knows so yes i
mean everybody wants to know
who could potentially i think this is a
more critical vice presidential debate
than anything we've ever seen
you think it's more important than ever
that the debate uh
the vp debate more important than ever
absolutely okay
i mean there's a greater dem i'm just
this is not brain surgery this is this
is demographics well some of us need
brain surgery because you know some of
us our head's been hit too many times
whether it was military and
sports
i can tell you that's what's wrong with
my middle son i mean every time i say
him i'm like you were definitely dropped
on your head
he's like thanks mom yeah especially on
national you know alive this is very
impressive for him so you're looking
forward to the
the vp debate are you looking more
forward to the next
presidential debate or the vp debate
where's that
i think people are going to tune in for
the next presidential debate because
they they need more live sports in their
lives so
um more brain bashing well look
they're going to come up with some new
strictures guidelines what have you but
i mean
look my second masters is in journalism
i i was impressed that chris wallace
held his cool
and you could tell that he was sweating
under his collar
because he was being put in such a
precarious position
do you think he did a good job chris
wallace i think he held it together
i really did a good job or no i mean he
he couldn't have done a worse job let's
put it that way
i mean if i was him i ripped my
microphone off and walked walked away
and said
you just duke it out if if this is how
you're going to comport
you're not here to do this i had i had
the twins initially
watching it my my soon to be 13 year old
twins initially
watching the debate once profanities
started flying i'm like
go to bed now really now i'm like this
is not how america operates
this is not what we were talking about
what was the moment you said no no
no no no but i just shut up no no was
that professional no that wasn't no
there was real profanity that i'm not
going to
twice two instances of it that i'm not
going to would you no there's no cursing
we've never cursed in our lives but
please
for you know our audience and also we
have to figure out what's going on
who did did trump drop f-bombs i didn't
know no no there wasn't an f-bomb i
didn't say that i mean profanity trump
debate
what did the letter start with it
started with a
without b senior reporter uses profanity
to describe what you ate
okay i'm trying to see what was said now
i'm actually curious it's not it's not
saying anywhere
did he actually i think danielle just
broke some breaking news over here
that that minor in journalism has really
uh
shown masters masters masters
come on that minor in journalism you're
like buddy it's a masters
i apologize there's uh there's a dream
here that says the son of a [ __ ] got
fired
is that the one uh yeah the language
pattern
so i'm very surprised trump would ever
use profanity you know
what i would like to know right now is
if the second debate was moderated not
by chris wallace at this point
but by danielle dimartino booth yeah
what would you do differently
a i would have one of those shot collar
things shock collar
a shock collar yeah if you say
if you say a bad word if you're gonna if
you're gonna hit below the belt
when you're supposed to be i don't know
the leader of the world
i need to have some comportment of some
type
either of them then you get to zap them
you're shocking trump and if if they
go if they go over their time because
it's it's 120 seconds
hopefully if you're the leader of the
free world you can gather your thoughts
in 120 seconds
so then then you i would have the other
button with the dunk the dunk tank
see now you're talking my language
because now he's looking for excitement
if it's looking
if this is like supposed to be the
apprentice meets the debate
meets the golden boxing ring you know
the golden girls the golden guys i love
that um and you're wondering why we're
watching the vice presidential debate
right okay
they're golden okay clogged arteries
so yes they're old they're old yeah so
why don't we why don't we do this first
of all there's a lot of memes that were
going on can you show us some of the
memes kai i think it's good to start
with uh
some real serious topics of the memes uh
uh this is one of them that came out can
you uh
our get along shirt okay biden and trump
i don't know why trump is shorter here
but
it is what it is do you have the other
one uh here's one that's very emotional
very emotional how much is that chris
wallace saving the day yeah
nice kerry and biden nice heartfelt this
one brought a tear
okay then go to the next one go to the
next one which was uh
you know uh do you have the other one or
no the one that
i give mario mario may want to send that
to you the one i sent to mario is pretty
funny as well
um now they're talking about changing
the format of the debate
now the conversation is what if they can
change the format of the debate a couple
different things came out
is i just looked at it right now you
were talking about it earlier a
possibility of a mic
mute meaning muting if you're going over
the uh moderator has the ability to just
press mute
and nobody can hear you um any thoughts
on that on being able to mute the other
person from speaking
well something needs to get done here or
do we just let
children just act like children i mean
what's up do we want more excitement we
want less excitement we want more order
do we want
trump being more trumpy like
what i will say is this and this is
being nonpartisan i know you're going to
think
as someone who is not a fan of donald
trump
just to watch the guy constantly
interrupt like i told you i taught
second grade when i was in my early 20s
yeah he was acting like a second grader
like hey buddy timmy i told you
to be quiet we have a class to run you
keep interrupting
i've told you a few times uh donnie i've
told you a few times
yeah how many times you got to tell
someone not that not that old man biden
was you know on his best behavior
chris what's that it had to be like it's
this is
everyone's like chris wallace saved the
day for saving private ryan over here
if he actually again nonpartisan
he needs to step in and be like guys we
are grown men here
what is going on here like stop it just
enough for this nonsense
but he was like excuse me uh uh if you
if you don't mind uh
uh perhaps um well would you consider
like shut your faces people well i mean
he's he is in a position where he's
supposed to be deferential these people
have been leaders of our country you i
mean you don't
you don't chastise the president you
don't you don't chastise him but he's
allowed to chastise anyone
uh-uh no no no you're suggesting that he
gets he gets down
with him i don't i don't i don't buy
that i'm not i'm not i'm just
i'm not saying that the moderator needs
to be debating someone but
if you're the moderator the key word is
moderate moderation
there was no moderation going on so so i
would take a couple what would you do
yes please status there was 70
interruptions
okay 70 interruptions in 90 minutes okay
i don't know if that's a lot or it's not
a lot but 70 interruptions seems like a
lot okay let's just say it's a big
number fine number one
the one thing is for sure wallace
if things don't go well with him at fox
he's got a job at cnn
100 okay possibly msnbc
he's got a job he came from the liberal
networks i know he did
roger ailes and murdoch himself they
hired him knowing full well that that he
was
at least to me i i did not know
and i've watched him for years i've
watched fox for years
i did not know that he was a
card-carrying democrat until
right before the debates because he's
always at least to me he's always gone
straight down the middle he's hard on
people on the left and the right
yeah he's like david brinkley used to be
he he would never
show his politics
in his job in his position and that's
that that's his job his job is to s
is to stay straight down the middle but
he showed it two days ago you're saying
that he
is in fact a democrat he is like he's
registered as a democrat or he's voted
that was in a june new york times
profile for me
he needs to be a registered independent
people that are moderating debates
see how it works cooper's going to be
moderating the debate you know cooper
anderson
is a little bit different i mean what's
so different about it he's man that's
sanderson cooper we know that he's on
the left like he's not even making
you know so that's why i don't have a
problem with that i don't have a problem
with that
go ahead that's the third debate then
cooper cooper is a third okay
the next the next one is uh scott
something i don't know who's he's got
bail he's got bail he's a big trump c
man c-span yeah can we bring our seats
up a little bit are you good
in the bottom up here you're good there
you go am i feeling short
a little bit i want the people to know
how big you are in real life like how
grand you are
all right so i'm not going to run right
now it's the other side buddy
there we go okay so
so yeah
interruptions wallace jobs cnn left
center left wherever he's at you're
uncomfortable with him whether he's in
the middle
you got to be in the middle it's
different than scott it's different in
cooper
you know here's a couple things about
the debate the whole thing about trying
to put a two-minute
thing on it my problem is the complete
opposite side
so here so here's what it is so
if you're debating somebody and
debate is about being overly prepared
you know i think yesterday tom said
something very good when we were having
lunch
he said the fact that an entrepreneur
like trump his entire life he's told
people what to do
people don't tell him what to do so he
comes from the standpoint of
who are you to tell me what to do i mean
even chris christie was trying to coach
this guy for debating
trump and trump's just kind of like i'm
going to go do it the way i've been
doing in my entire life you better
believe the one song that trump has on
repeat in his car if he ever listens to
any songs
it's i did it my way it's trump it's he
is a full-on i did it my way right
he doesn't listen to you to his wife to
his
kids to maybe he listened to his
daughter he doesn't listen to the media
he doesn't listen to his advisors
so why anybody is surprised i'm
surprised that's number one is that a
good thing though i'm not telling you
it's a good thing or bad
i'm just telling you who he is i'm
giving you his uh he doesn't listen
anyway
that says okay here's the other part the
other part for me is
okay biden kept reading his cards
what does that mean that you're reading
your card it's preparation maybe you
didn't write it
trump just looked at the camera like
this and he spoke you know where trump
stands
you don't know where biden stands you
know where biden's team stands but you
don't know where biden stands
so you have two different things to to
go with
one where you know what trump is going
to do because he wears it on his sleeve
the other one is somebody that's overly
been coached that is going to say what
his team's told them to say
those are the two things that we're
looking at so if you're still if you're
sitting there saying
we got to change the format and maybe be
being able to mic one of the guys if he
interrupts the other person
well that's exactly what a lot of the
audience doesn't want to see
if you're doing a debate specifically
for people in the world of journalism
they got to do what they want to do if
you're doing a debate for the average
person to make up their mind
you can make up their mind after a
two-minute answer but okay next
boom okay next boom okay next you can't
do that because then you don't have
enough momentum for a person to be able
to make up their mind
i want to be able to like for example
you know uh
george jorgensen's camp reached out to
us they said they'd like to do a uh uh
uh
writing stuff on here right what do you
call it joe jorgensen said they're
they're wanting to come up and be a
guest because you know she was not on
the debate and she's the libertarian
candidate and uh you know i said if you
want to come down here we'll give you a
couple hours and you can kind of share
your thoughts right come down and share
your thoughts and tell us what you think
about
current politics when when you saw
sanders go on rogan
he spoke and he kind of gave his answers
when he saw tulsi gabbard going around
talking
you saw answers when you're seeing
people going around talking
today's world the reason why these
podcasts are doing very well
is because a long form does well when
she came the first time when we sat down
and we spoke it was two hours i don't
know what it was it was a good two hours
people finally got a chance to say holy
who is what who is this lady she's
brilliant i fit
this is amazing we learn about her
the audience that makes the decisions
and says what wow
i like her i like her views i don't like
her here i don't like her here
but i she's brilliant i like the way she
put things up we were able to make a
decision on her
based on a couple hours right okay now
maybe the audience is trying to say
we don't like this 90-minute format and
we don't like this regimented two-minute
crap that you guys are doing
maybe that's what the audience is saying
well they they get the town hall yeah
next time it's a much more open casual
thing is that what it is next time it's
a town
hall questions answers i don't even
think 90 minutes is a long time
i don't think 90 minutes i agree it
should be at least two hours i think
it's more than that i don't even think
two hours
let's go ten hours with it let's do it
i'm thinking let's get crazy i'm
actually being very serious with you
guys
three hours take a break you can do
three hours
with 15 minute breaks three uh
increments go one hour 15 minute go one
hour 15 minutes go one hour 50 minutes
or go in 90 minutes two times take a 20
minute break
go just like football you got half times
do 290 minutes
and let us talk and it's not two minutes
let's see if biden can give a ten minute
answer
so yeah you can actually go through
something given what happened a few
nights ago you would have a lot of
official reviews
you would have a lot of timeouts fact
checks are for what penalties
penalties but you know what i
here's the other thing i would do here's
the other thing i would do yes sir this
is the other thing i would do
one time we brought a couple guys here
to debate marijuana okay
if you know me uh i'm not a cigarette
guy i can't stand cigarettes
long story anyways i was going to go a
whole different smoking cigar though
every once in a while
when i'm with matt sapala that's it
shout out to papa
you know i think i've mentioned five
cigars in my life four of them with matt
yeah so
it's but they came in they debated
marijuana one of the one of the ones was
uh the development
director from normal is where she came
from and the other one was a
navy u.s navy intelligence uh uh uh
commander of u.s navy intelligence he
came over here you see him all the time
on fox and cnn he came over here
we put the debate right behind that and
we went 90 minutes right
the last 30 minutes of the format of the
debate the way i did it is they talk to
each other i'm not involved
talk to each other i want them to talk
to each other
go you did this go talk give them 30
minutes dude when there's a fight
let them fight you the fight is not
about the moderator
let them fight so now i understand where
somebody may come back and say
well what if it gets ugly whenever it
got ugly i kind of held back i'm like
hey you know can you do this let him
answer
let her answer you did a little bit of
that but let them talk and then this is
what we did which was very interesting
we came back we asked the guys what
should we do with the debate and we said
how about at the bottom
we write out green he was right
red you were wrong so we fact checked it
so what if we watch it on three hour
format and he says
i never said you stupid bastards fact
check yes you did
biden's wrong boom i never said that
boom
yes trump you're wrong i never said this
to
boom you're right he did never say that
so there's a fact checker that's being
done from both sides so there's a fox
fact checker there's a cnn fact checker
in that moment the audience is sitting
there saying
oh this is kind of cool i love that i
love that idea not let's wait till the
next day because how many people
actually go out and do their own
research to find out if
they didn't say stupid bastard i think
that's an exciting format
live fact-checking i say you go three
hours
first part is controlled by the
moderator guess what's the second part
go light it up talk to one another face
to face
i want to sit like this i want to buy it
that also tells us where they're at let
them let them let the audience kind of
realize how they handle pressure because
in reality daniel behind closed doors
when they're sitting with schumer and
pelosi and they're screaming at each
other at the white house
that's what's life going to be anyways
when you're running the organization so
screen let's see how you handle meetings
behind closed doors let's learn about
you let's see who can handle composure
the two can work together maybe it's not
going to work in trump's favor maybe
it's not going to work in byden's favor
but i want us to sit like this and the
moderator says
listen it's officially your turn you
have a choice
pick a topic next one is your choice you
pick whatever topic you want you say
okay i want to go through one topic
what's that
my topic is coronavirus how you handled
it great why did you do that
why did i why did obama okay go next 20
minutes
boom ding ding ding ding ding go 20
minutes next topic trump what what
product what topic you want to talk
about
i want to talk about why for 47 years
you've not done [ __ ] and it comes out
saying well you're
talking about and then they go back and
forth that's the format i want to see
because open format no matter how much
when we had uh
jarrah here jared said something very
interesting and a crash of license to
carry she said
look people you know the question was
asked what was the question when she
said if somebody oh somebody came with a
paintball gun and started shooting up a
car on the freeway do you remember that
story
and you asked the question did you ask
it okay i think you asked it
so can the person take a gun out and
point it at him
okay and she said you can
but i just want you to know in that
moment there's no way you're going to be
able to fire exactly at a car because
you've never been in that situation
before right
yeah so when we're saying yes i said oh
yesterday you guys don't know what i
arrested somebody the night before last
night at 10 o'clock she was telling that
whole story about what happened night
before
as tough as somebody acts it's very
different when a real fight
fight breaks out as as tough as you
think when i went in the military man
when we
did our first exercise where you're
supposed to low crawl over m60s firing
above you
and it's 11 o'clock at night and you're
supposed to low crawl in mud
the biggest guy with tattoos on his back
is the one that got up that couldn't
handle it
toughest guy can handle it i'm telling
you alone you're like you
out of everybody used the smallest guy
was the toughest guy so you don't know
this kind of stuff
okay when you go into a negotiation room
things really get down
the guy that's like a nice salesy guy
you think he's good but on the
negotiations he's very nervous what
happened
there so this is the part hey since
you've had 47 years of politics and i've
been doing 50 years of business i'm
trump you're biden
let's see who can handle pressure the
most on the spotlight let's talk about
topics
no one gets involved that would get me
to stick there so oh my gosh this was
sick
then i can make my decision for myself i
think that'll help the average american
to say
um i can see why they say
nothing gets done with you behind closed
doors yeah i can't vote for i just saw
the true colors of you
that's how you find out about who the
leaders are i may be wrong but that's
just my thing
i i actually ten thousand percent agree
with you because
behind closed doors if you're in a
negotiating room you're sitting at the
table
you have to be able to interact with
somebody if somebody's that's like buddy
listen
can we have this conversation right here
for a second all you're doing is yelling
here's what i'm gonna say
because that's what is the problem right
now with nancy pelosi and steve mnuchin
and they're behind closed doors they're
trying to get this freaking
second stimulus exactly trying to get a
stimulus deal done why can't this deal
get done now they're back to where they
were square one
four months ago ridiculous with the
heroes act or the heels act or is it the
keras act part two
what's going on behind closed doors
basically you were saying what you're
saying is
let's open the room let's open the vault
and let's see what actually hope it's
going to happen
therapy session you ever seen the the
the um
incredible movie based on true stories
uh a
very heartfelt movie couples retreat
super serious very seriously
i was waiting i was waiting and i'm like
gone with the wind oh my god
you ever seen the part where they say
singles island this is your island
married island john fever is asking a
question and then they sit down and they
say with the therapist
and they say so how are things perfect
just perfect john fever and his wife
how's everything very good oh he's a
great so say something good about your
husband he's a great father say
something good about her he's a great
mother
say something and then all of a sudden
you saw that
and she let him go sometimes you got to
do that let him lose man
like in a if you goddy
fighting ward it's known as one of the
greatest boxing matches of all time
today referees would have stopped that
fight but it became wonderful if you
want to go
watch a fight like a real fight fight
it's gotti ward
go turn it on and watch it bam
bam god he gets down his ribs he can't
breathe
nine seconds gets back up bam bam
ward gets down rip gets back let these
people
fight and let us make a decision for
ourselves and step out of the way
moderated we're putting too much value
on a moderator half of it moderator
driven
the other half get out of their way let
them fight let's see what they do i
think it'll be so entertaining
danielle do you like that idea uh i
would probably be in a different room
you don't like her but you don't like
you don't like uh you don't like
people going out and fighting what don't
you like about pat's idea
go back and google george washington's
farewell address
september the 17th 1896. danielle i know
that back and forth like
come on that's all i do is i watch stuff
like that me and kai in our spare time
come on
actually i don't know but do your
history we
i mean these are men who were at war who
were fighting
spilling blood fighting for our country
and
when you hear by the way he's the only
landslide
times two president george w george w
yes the other one the other one the
original the first one yeah
but when you go and you listen to his
speech you you get the sense that
he understood coalition building and he
knew what it was
to build a team and he knew how
important it was to unite
the country and to and and that if you
tear it apart then you make it weaker
so and and i think that that is
why you've seen in this particular
administration the revolving
door going as quickly as it has you know
you can't keep anybody in office
and i think it's if it's my way or the
highway then maybe
maybe that's not the right
characteristics for somebody to be
president
because you have to build coalitions in
order to get things done
in washington when you're behind closed
doors if you're just slinging mud and
nothing is accomplished
you're not you're not making forward
progress you have to actually
accomplish things and get things done
and by the way for everybody
it doesn't so you're not just working
for the people who voted for you you're
working for the entire country that's
your job
and it has to be you have to look out
for everybody in the country
so to bring it back to pat's point
you're saying
he wants to see what actually happens
behind closed doors you're basically
saying
you know we kind of know what's
happening behind we know closed doors
there's a lot of money actually going
out
in words results
there have been more people who who've
stormed out of the oval office oh i
don't disagree with that i mean
so you know what's going on what i'm
saying that's good for for the people
that are
to to see his sides because we've not
seen that before no no i i don't
disagree with that at all
but if if nothing is accomplished then
again they're there to do a job they're
not there to get
press they're not there to get memes
they're not there to create
tweets they are there to get to do a
job that is a duty to the to the world's
biggest economy i'll say this to you
okay very very good point but i'll say
this
to you somebody just commented right now
saying that uh biden interrupted paul
ryan 82 times in a vp debate back in
which i remember because he was
constantly interrupting him look i have
a friend of mine tom
we go to a baseball game score is 2-1
i'm half asleep he's saying what a great
game
i'm like what is great about this game
he says this is an ultimate pitching
duel
this is a great pitching duel i'm like
pitch i didn't come to watch a pitching
duel
i came to see what home runs you want to
see some steroids
dudes knocking it out i see a pitching
duel if you want to see
what saved baseball was 98 here's the
point watch this
danielle what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to create a format that pleases
everybody what's great about the format
i'm suggesting is the first 90 minutes
we have your attention
the next 90 minutes you go to sleep but
the next 90 minutes
is you know the freaks come out at night
the fans are going to watch the second
round
from the debate i said the freaks i i
think
as as what do you guys think about this
idea about though if you're listening to
this
disappointing as the ratings were i
think people are tuning in next time
with popcorn so i do because it is
it's going to be pure entertainment you
think so let's just take it to where you
want to see it you want to see the
second half of the debate
shirts off gloves on gloves bite in
trump
fighting actually who wins in a real
street fight i think that'd be terrible
who wins in a real street fight pat
who'd win a real street fight
um two 70-something year old men
going at it who is who would win the
streak what do you guys think in the
office i can't see trump throwing a
punch
i can't see trump even throwing a punch
in a fight no i don't see trump i see
trump as the guy that he has people that
fight for him i was about to say no he
can't fight for himself
i don't he would outsource that i think
so
i think so by the way you know yeah i
don't that's not what i want to see guys
i'm not asking about
whether you know i want to see that
happen what i'm asking about is i want
to see your true colors i want you to
talk to one another
sit down face each other you know one of
the best parts in the debate was when
the the last time they were asked or so
hillary tell us what's the one thing you
respect about trump the most
i think trump went first uh uh and as so
trump what do you like about
uh hillary the most is the fact that she
never gives up she's a fighter yeah
hillary what do you like about trump the
most
his kids you have to give him respect
for his kids he's raised his kids
you know so except for eric but whatever
that's another topic
he's not bad i mean you and eric would
get along you know you guys would
definitely get along in the mind
i would get along in a with ivanka
probably yeah so
but but the point i'm trying to make to
you is there's different options the
women won the dna war by the way
in that family anyways i agree it's
actually a good point so that's all i'm
saying i'm just saying let's see a
different form have you seen how tall
baron trump is oh my gosh he's seven
four
he's not seven he's seven he's he's
taller he's taller than his outside six
seven he's a tall dude where is this guy
he was standing next to pence do we have
a picture of that
yes standing next to pence i mean minnie
mike yeah
we show that but you like mike pence
mike needed a milk crate i i
i'm i'm a midwest kind of a traditional
conservative kind of a person and
so where's the debate my first first
time i ever was in indianapolis airport
june
2016. i'm walking through the
indianapolis airport i'm taking my boys
to the military academy where they
attend in culver
where pence summers and i see this sign
that says
indiana's got the best pension in the
country you know
fiscal blah blah and i'm like you like
that and i'm like googling i'm like
governor
state of indiana who is this guy and a
month later
he was he was announced today you don't
know who he was
prior to that i did not know who pence
was so interesting okay press play buddy
baron's out of the shot yeah you're like
his head is out of the shot you're like
dead
so let's take a look at this so trump so
here's some stats for you trump biden
clash was watched by
at least 73 million viewers
down 13 i thought so the television
audience for the debate was down for the
first debate
between trump and hillary clinton in
2016 but it was higher almost every
other debate in modern history
by almost any measure the audience was
massive massive today's
tuesday's clash was the biggest event on
american tv
super bowl last february february
nielsen said an estimated 73.1 million
people watch tuesday's debate across 16
channels
i mean you know it's it wasn't a bad
uh uh showing if you think about how
many people showed up to see it do you
think it's gonna be a bigger show and
second one look they're saying that
voters are more engaged
across the demographic spectrum than
they've been in a very long time i mean
if we don't see high voter turnout i'll
be shocked because of the amount
of engagement i mean it's it's what
everybody it's what school
children are talking about i mean this
is p and this is not
a bad thing by the way we i mean they
did a
quiz every year on constitution day
which is my birthday they they do a quiz
they ask americans if
if they can name the five rights in the
first amendment
and if they can name the three branches
of the government
and this year was the best showing that
they've had ever
so in other words people are really
paying attention to
america and that is awesome i mean if
you've got
people engaged and studying our history
studying our constitution
that is a great thing i mean you know
knowledge is power period end and as
long as we stay smart
we're going to stay the big superpower
in the world period you know who we have
to thank for that
george w i think we owe we do
owe it to trump for awakening people to
say hold on what's going on here whether
you like him or don't like him
he's awoken people and you agree or no
and and and i would say to him
he disagree to his credit i would say
that you're never going to be able to
put
china the china genie back in the bottle
i don't think that there will ever be
less scrutiny no matter who's in the
white house i think that
all americans now place china in a
different place
in their minds and i think that that
credit goes to donald trump
for china and you think that's a good
thing well i do
to walk around and say oh we know
they've been stealing for years and be
kind of okay fine agnostic about it
that's not okay and i think that that is
the bright light that he has shown on
this situation is to say
this is national security this is our
identity these people are
they want to steal from us it's not
acceptable he's bullying the bully
china's been bullying u.s realistically
for a long time yeah yeah
so i mean you got to plan for it you got
to plot them for it to see what's going
on so
let's talk a little bit business let's
talk a little bit business so harley
davidson's leaving india world's largest
motorcycle market i don't get that
that's a little confusing that's a it's
a demographic dream
yeah they're young people coming up
according to figures uh by this
society of indian automobile
manufacturers hardy sold a mere 103
units in july 176 last month there were
rumors
that harley davidson was planning to
partner with a local company as ktm and
triumph
have done but it has now opted out to
leave the market all together
maybe indians don't like harley i don't
know what is it competition
competition in india honda yamaha
potholes but harley's got a different
audience
it's more expensive than those other
brands it is more expensive but it's
hardly
when you i don't think it has the same
the same stature or stigma
like in india i don't think that it does
happen in america you don't think that
there are rebels in india you know
when's the last time you saw an indian
guy that's like
get on the back of my heart everybody
come on they're coming wrong accent you
know what they don't have
in india get down to back in my heart
come on let's go baby
i don't see it not politically correct
danielle this is not called
what they don't you guys are missing
something fundamental you've got a geeky
economist in here
what india does not have is highways
they don't have highways they got
potholes no no they literally
their infrastructure is in the i mean
american companies that are there are
going to make a flipping
fortune because compared to china
they don't have highways they don't have
a freeway system
i mean somebody's gonna gonna have to
come in and invent that and i mean
you think about harley's on the open
road going to the mojave desert with the
wind flying through your hair
man that's not happening you're stuck in
traffic i was there and i got to tell
you
they are some of the most reckless safe
drivers i've seen in my life and
reckless combinations
safe drivers yes that's like exactly a
word because
they drive so close to each other
and you're thinking the entire time
you're thinking about the crash
everything's okay
it's under control that's like driving
in a with a new york taxi cab i was
gonna say
drive with them new york taxi cab
drivers times worse yeah but tell me an
indian driver have you ever seen an
accident
no no no taxi cab driver in an accident
no same they're incredible yeah so
reckless and safe at the same time
reckless and safe at the same time so
they are let's talk about layoffs kpmg
all state and goldman sachs big layoffs
kpmg laid off 1400 employees
its latest firm and professional
services industry is reduced headcount
because of coronavirus pandemic
allstate one of us largest insurers has
uh says plans to lay off 3 800 employees
the layoff represents about eight
percent of insurance approximately 46
000 employees so 46
3800 is going to be gone of the job cuts
about a thousand are tied to the
company's pandemic related fund to
policyholders all state chief executive
thomas wilson said in an interview
goldman sachs bloomberg news which first
reported about the layoffs said the bank
was
looking to cut 400 jobs roughly one
percent of its workforce citing
people familiar with the matter and in
disney
28 000 people have been let go walt
disney has announced it will lay off 20
000 people at their theme parks the
layoff applied to domestic employees
of which about 67 percent are part-time
so what do you think's going on there
so the the part i mean no insensitivity
but the part-time workers don't move the
economic needle as much as
the high-end workers do it
the the problem that we're seeing we we
got fresh layoff data this morning from
challenger gray that they track
they track aggregate layoff
announcements throughout the country 2.1
million layoffs announced so far this
year
and that is higher than any year in u.s
history including 2001 was
was the prior high the problem that
they're seeing the problem that i'm
seeing is that
is that layoffs are going up the income
ladder the top two quintiles the top 40
percent of earners in america account
for 61
of spending can you say that one more
time the top two quintiles the top 40
percent
of earners in america who make the most
account for 61 of consumption
and our economy is consumption-driven
it's two-thirds consumption
if you if you want to think about it
differently they account for 42 of us
gdp
that's a lot of money so when you see
white-collar layoffs
there is a trickle-down effect but not
in a good way because the small
businesses that rely on them the dry
cleaners the restaurants
that they're the ones who start to
suffer if the biggest spenders
lose their jobs what's your solution
danielle you i mean you're an economist
what's what's going on here what's the
look there's more stimulus what is it
yes on more stimulus but for god's sake
get something out of it
i mean so i mean look at least the
chinese
get something for their money i mean
they've got high-speed rails you know
we've got potholes that would swallow a
small car
we can't even agree think of all the oil
field workers who are out of a job their
skills are transferable
they can repair the bridges they can
repair the tunnels you can put them to
work immediately
the corps of engineers has got trillions
and trillions of dollars of repairs to
do
do job skill training in germany they
did job skill training starting in
after the financial crisis they came in
and they said you know what
if if they can't work in the old
industry then we're going to retrain
them for the new industry their youth
unemployment is in the single digits
unlike the rest of europe which is a
cesspool
of very high youth unemployment give
people
a way to make a living people don't want
to have money thrown at them
but we need a return on the investment
for the money that
for the taxpayer money that's being
spent otherwise you're just going to
put another band-aid on it and business
travel's not coming back anytime soon
and yet we're going to bail the airlines
out again
dot dot dot and we're going to throw
money at people to not work
that is not the way america was designed
to be
people that they have integrity in in in
their in their work ethic
so help them find a way to earn an
income for their families
period pay them to work not to stay home
yes
okay or train them if they don't have
the adequate skills fine whatever what
about infrastructure you alluded to that
initially no i mean
we we have we easily have four trillion
dollars of infrastructure spending that
that we could tend to
and think about it think if you start
repairing all the infrastructure around
the country
you're shortening somebody's commute
time in the future
you're making people's way of life a lot
easier in the future
and you're also making sure that other
countries like china that have built up
world-class infrastructure aren't going
to cook our goose one day
so 64 of people say the economy is worse
than it was a year ago well no
kidding 76 of democrats say the economy
is worse only 50
republicans say the economy is worse and
there's been a debate about a k-shaped
recovery the kind of
recession uh is characterized by the
fortunes of workers that go into one or
two directions the first segment of the
population has its prospects
recover from a downturn almost
immediately and another suffers much
longer the differences between the rich
and the poor
do you think the wealth gap is getting
wider
during the coronavirus did this thing
make it wider or not at all without a
doubt that's without a doubt that's
where
jay powell and his happy printing press
come in so the biggest companies have
been bailed out
uh companies that should have gone out
of business it's called creative
destruction you get rid of the
unprofitable inefficient operators you
make room for the new entrance
it's the way productivity grows but we
haven't done that instead we've kept
all the businesses that are big and have
access to the capital markets
access to high-yield bonds junk bonds
we've kept all of them in business
he's kept the stock market at all-time
highs so that
the wealth that the 55 percent of
americans who own stocks they're feeling
awesome and he's also bought up a third
of mortgages
he owns a third of the mortgage market
that goes a long way towards giving you
a 2.96 percent 30-year conventional
mortgage rate
so americans who have built up record
levels of equity in their homes
have pulled a hundred billion dollars
out in home equity
in the past six months alone ended
september 30.
a hundred billion dollars of cash so if
you own a home and if you own stocks
you're feeling awesome you are living
the dream
if you don't you have a whole different
perspective on
life in america hmm that's what they
talked about this k
shape that's called right so initially
they were talking about it's going to be
a v
shape recovery right it's going to it's
going to well for the top it's the top
of the cake it is a v
okay and for the bottom you took the k
and you put it into a v
that's good that's the thing the top the
top of the k
some industries do well sorry but the
other ones don't well they were thrown
out
at the top of the k applies to the
halves they were also talking about a
u-shaped
recovery right it was going to take a
bit longer than i was talking about
worst case scenario was the l-shaped
recovery right
if we don't i don't know if it's halves
and half's knots i think it's industry
no but if if again 55 of americans own
stocks
so the other 45 are not enjoying the
fruits of stocks being at all so what's
the solution
what's the solution if the other 45 or
not again we have to enable people
to live the dream you're an entrepreneur
right you've brought lots of young
employees on in your time i did but
95 of them quit
well i can't i can't do um what i'm
we're surrounded by young people who i'm
saying
on the sales side no no what i'm saying
on the sales side so
here's a challenge so so let's talk
about it pretty theory are you familiar
with the pareto theory
the predator theory is that eighty
percent of works going to get down by
twenty percent
well this is not a new 80 20 rule 80 20
rule applies in sports if you
yesterday steve uh davis scored 34
points
and you know he's the guy that scored
the most points lebron james teammate
ever 28.8 points a game
no one's ever okay you know 80 of points
were scored by 20
of guys pretty much if you look at that
number it's not the you know
you see the few producing the most so
then
the the challenge with this concept of
the rich getting richer the poor getting
poorer
i have a challenge with that and here's
my challenge with that
if if the challenge is to crucify
the guys that made the right decision to
invest and the guys didn't
why are we saying the guys that are
making money are bad people they're
making money because
they stayed in the market they're not
bad people but the people who don't own
stocks
surely they don't have they're getting
buying credit cards
they don't have any money to invest i
know what it is to be in that situation
my dad was a cashier at a 99 cent store
i mean i
parents got a divorce i was 49k and dead
at 22 years old
i get it i had the option to go to vegas
every other weekend and party or i had
the option to save money i hated saving
money
so let me ask you a question yeah do you
think that the 80 20 rule
applied a few generations ago
or do you think something has happened
to the work ethic because we've given
a generation of children you know sorry
sorry boy
but that we've that we've given an
entire generation of children he's glad
you referred to
the children everything that they wanted
time magazine did an article
six years ago titled you know how
millennials are becoming narcissists
right
all they care about is themselves and
all this other stuff and you read the
article says oh millennials are this
millennials are that they want to take
pictures of themselves
they think they're so important they
think they're this they think they're
that you know how the article ended
the article ended if or here's how it
says the article says
or if we are the ones that are making
fun of millennials
for only thinking about themselves maybe
we're just getting older
and we forgot how we used to be so what
i'm trying to say is
that story about when i was younger i
was growing and going to
the school and it was snowing and it was
a mountain both ways you know this whole
story you hear about
people working so hard so i think times
have been hard i think obviously it's
been harder than what it is today today
is easier than it's ever been
before they had their coming of age in
the middle of a financial crisis i mean
i do think it's easier today ever before
to make money even in sales like i'll
give you an example
instagram if i want to find leads today
i can send 100 dms a day to network with
people
40 years ago if i'm in sales i'm doing
real estate i have to have quarters in
my car and if i'm driving an hour to
person so man they don't pick up and
it's raining i got to find a local
you know a phone booth and wait for
somebody to finish their call
yeah i mean it's a joke today to make
money i've got news for you
the generation behind the millennials
my experience the interns we've had they
are work horses gen z
gen z yeah they can't work and work
and work and they're serious about it
they save money
they're they're they're just they have a
different mindset
and i'm not too worried about this
country's future i'm not
because i know that there's an entire
generation coming up
that has that that will
weather and withstand as long as they're
not trading day trading yeah
um but there's another generation that
that does have a good old-fashioned
work ethic and i'm i'm hopeful all right
yeah what's the 80 20 uh concept pretty
theory
p-r-e-d-o predo i think is it a t or a d
okay whatever the 80 20 rule what i you
you that's right pareto
so here's where i'm going with this yeah
um
we all have decisions to make okay we
all have 24 hours right we're all gonna
sleep you know
six to eight hours some sleep four some
sleep eight some sleep ten
but what are you doing with the the rest
of your day some people choose to spend
their mornings
on a with us on a podcast learning
getting smarter
some people are reading some people at
night kai reads 10 books a day
some people do that some people in their
spare time choose to
slack off you know smoke weed play video
games
bs you know it's also about what you do
with your time so there's i'm sure
a correlation with the 55 percent who
are investing in america
who are reading or watching podcasts
like this first the person who does
their nine to five they get off they get
their paycheck
you know they smoke a joint they sit at
home they do nothing they play video
games they don't work out
there has to be a correlation with that
but i think the current virus is gonna
end that i really do
it's gonna end what the what i think the
coronavirus is gonna change the way
work is approached i don't think the
nine to fivers got
too long of a life expectancy in the
workforce i think that
the coronavirus has expedited automation
like put it into a hyperdrive so i i
mean it's
living through it very powerful what you
just said by the way did you hear what
you just said
so so so you're saying the nine to fiver
is not gonna have a long lifespan and
what coronavirus did
automation is going to expedite that
process look if you're joe q
human resources manager and you've got
all these people working remotely right
now
all you have to do is pull up a
spreadsheet and you just look at their
numbers and you're like this person's
productive oh i always thought this
person was a slacker
look they are and it's objective yep and
you just go
delete and that's what but but now we
see i mean you know
if a working mother who's got three kids
doing three
you know three different grades doing
you know different curriculums
and she can still produce because who
knows if she's up at two o'clock in the
morning when everybody
when everything finally settles down but
all i'm saying
is that this is going to be something
that separates the wheat from the chaff
i almost said something different but
yeah but but and it will be a game
changer in how
the workforce itself evolves into
its new self small businesses in america
used to employ
lots of people human capital
now people don't want to interact as
much with humans so even small
businesses are automating
so it is time to realize i'm back on my
china soapbox
it is time to realize that they're
inventing the next generation of
technology
and we need to get busy and make sure
that we are in front of them
i agree and i want to continue this
topic but i want to give a shout out to
a couple people we have one guy up there
i think his name was boris he gave five
dollars to say trump's going to win it
by landslide and we just have razvan
ionotos gave 50 i believe hi pat former
international arm wrestling champion
from romania just so you know i will
take you down i'm a pretty good armrest
i will take
you down you arm computer science start
it out fail two tech
startups i want to work for
valuetainment how do we make this happen
okay
so you can send an email and we'll we're
always taking resumes but let me get
back to this let me get back to this so
yeah i read a story one time and here's
what the story was
it's it's a very interesting story i got
to tell you this
so this uh king
finds out that this one guy who lives in
his community
dated his daughter okay and he's not
happy about it
okay because if you're going to date his
daughter you got to marry his daughter
he's a king how dare you
touch his daughter so she's a princess
yes so this guy
goes and starts telling everybody
look i know the day the king's gonna die
he starts telling everybody i'm telling
you guys i had
a message that came from god and i know
exactly
when the king is gonna die everybody
starts asking when is he gonna die when
he's gonna die
he says if you want it if you want me to
tell you when the king's gonna die take
me to the king
so they take him to the king and the
king is
furious that this guy messed around with
his daughter
so they asked him they said i hear you
know when i'm gonna die
he says i know exactly when you're gonna
die when am i gonna die
a day after i die so he says
what happened he says you will die the
day after i die
i got that calling from god now it's not
the truth he's just telling this to the
king
so the king was thinking about executing
this guy that messed around with his
daughter
now he's sitting there saying there you
go damn it if i kill this guy
i'm dying the next day this guy's got to
live as long as possible
he then got a place in the palace and
live with the king
i love it now whether this is a true
story or not it is what it is it's a
wonderful story
what is the moral of the story here's
the moral of the story
um when you were younger and you were
going out partying with your friends
you always had that one friend that was
a good fighter
maybe it wasn't the best looking guy but
was a good fighter and he was maybe
annoying but you knew if a fight broke
down broke out
he's going to brawl and protect you well
if you were
if it's friday night you think about
going to the party you're going to
someone's place you're like [ __ ] i don't
know if i want to invite him when i look
i'm going to invite him because if
something happens i'm just glad he's on
my team okay then he had the one friend
that was very good at going to the club
and he would go walk to the girls at the
bar
and say hey ladies how are you look i
see you guys are here with some friends
i got some friends here
can i introduce them let's go maybe we
can have a drink come on there was a one
friend that was very good at going and
like somebody like you
very good at going and saying hey come
on down you know let's let me introduce
you to ultimate wingman
so the ultimate wig match right right
guess what yeah and the point is you
always wanted to go out with that guy
then do you have the one friend that had
the connections at the bar and the
bartender was his best friend he can get
drinks on the house
you always wanted to have that one
person go to the club with you right
party with you
this is for the people that were in that
scene the point is
every one of those people locked in
their position for friday night to go
out
the fighter the connector and the one
that knew how to talk to the girls
they're they're gonna be invited to
every party they're going to be invited
i think people today have to really take
a close look
and rather than saying the rich are
getting richer and this is not fair and
all this other stuff
you better find a way to make yourself
irreplaceable today in the marketplace
if you don't find a way to create
new skill sets improve get better the
next
5 10 15 20 years are going to be very
very scary and hard for you and your
family i fully agree
with what you just said and it's gonna
expedite the process because
the stock morning brew sends an email
shout out to morning brew they send an
email out and they say
here's the companies that are doing good
q3 that did good q3 and it showed the
fact that i think uh
uh five or what five no fiver was number
two
zoom was up 88 percent in their stock if
you can't pull that up
zoom was up 88 percent fiverr was on
that list and on the bottom who was down
you were looking at this like ooh these
are kind of tough places to be
moral the story is there's never ever
been an easier time to make money
there's never
ever been an easier time to get in front
of decision makers there's
never ever been an easier time to sell
there's never ever been an easier time
to become wealthy there's never ever
been an easier time to create wealth for
you and your family
yet at the same time if you smoke weed
and you party and you kick back and you
relax and you don't read the books and
you netflix and chill 24 7. you go to
every single party everybody invites you
when you come home from work rather than
reading the book you sit there and watch
a new netflix series that you connected
to on episode number 93
i have watched every show of whatever
whatever shown you brag about it at work
the next day
there's a reason why you're broken quite
frankly i don't feel bad for you
because you've been sucked in by the
entertainment i don't wake up in the
morning saying oh my god i had a call
this morning with one of my guys
and we had a very very good conversation
together okay very very good
conversation together
and i told him i said look you have to
realize a couple of things man you
we have paid you a lot of money this
year you've made a lot of money
your family's taken care of you've done
a great things for your life
you've done a great things for your
family i said but it's coming down to a
point in your life right now
where people need to stop motivating you
i said i understand at some point
someone's got to motivate you i
understand at some point someone's got
to get you going
but eventually the motivator needs to
learn to become self-motivated sure
i have no problem motivating somebody
but my ultimate outcome of motivating
you is to eventually no longer need to
motivate you because the goal is for you
to eventually be self-motivated so
i don't need this message anymore now
it's about direction first comes
motivation
then comes direction then comes
execution if the american people
had five months where stimulus income is
coming your way whatever the timeline
was
you had the ability to take a master
class learn a skill set go learn
negotiation
if you had the time to improve yourself
and you didn't and you're unemployed i'm
sorry
five months of a break was given to you
to improve yourself you didn't it's
nobody's fault
i don't feel bad for you and now we're
talking about another couple trillion to
throw at the same
problem so again the return for
taxpayers
is not all you have to do is is be in
front of
a plumber or an electrician or if your
air conditioner breaks
and just you know see what you've got to
pay this guy to walk through your front
door
okay hi and he's what 40 50 years old
clearly there are jobs to be had in the
world there's an
exodus to the exurbs and the suburbs and
people are buying
more homes this is low-hanging fruit
people i mean
we need we do need more vocational
training in this country
but there are also ways that you can
pull yourself up by your bootstraps and
learn the skill yourself
and if you're seeing people make money
then that means that that's a good place
to be
period and it and by the way fixing your
air conditioning
is not automated fixing your commode is
not automated so just
think about things that are going to be
recession proof in the future
and go there i talked to pablo's holmen
is it holmen that i said yeah
pablo's holdman i don't know if you know
pablo's home is he's one of the greatest
hackers of our generation
he's got a video on youtube tedx i think
23 million views and he's on the biggest
youtube uh
tedx speakers uh when he gave the talk
he would sit here right now within five
minutes he has all your passwords on
your phone all the passwords on your
phone that's what he does for a living
he's that good he says he would go to
starbucks and sit around and just find
people's passwords
that's what he did for a living he's a
professional hacker he was a number
three employee
is it blue origin the first spacex blue
origin which is a company started by
amazon to go to the moon
he was a number three employee and he's
directly worked with
jeff bezos and bill gates okay look what
he said he said something very
interesting
here's a hacker hackers are very weird
they're very different
you ask him a question and say did you
go to college and how come you didn't go
to college he says
you don't know what hackers are hackers
get kicked out of college we don't get
to go to college colleges don't want us
to go to college because all we do is
mess with their systems
so colleges want us out of college like
don't come over here because we're so
curious we want to get into a system
and figure stuff out so no hackers don't
go to college i said okay
he says do you realize the last uh the
last 200 years
how many jobs mankind has created
last 200 years it's a very interesting
stat last 200 years how many jobs has
been created for example
changing tires it's a job how many
people do it
10 000 people but it's one job okay
customer service
it's a job how many people do it tens of
millions but it's
one job right how many jobs do you think
man has created the last two hours how
many professions
how many professions okay jobs where you
can make five bucks an hour 10 bucks an
hour millions of dollars per year how
many different jobs
my gut is telling me less than you would
think it's actually much bigger number
really and it's not professional because
profession would be financial advisor
realtor
you know a mortgage ex it's jobs
occupation occupation
i go move a box from here i'm a mover
i'm a
trash i'm a cleaner i'm just how many
jobs you think we've created last
200 years like look right here okay look
what's happening here
what would you say you do yourself here
would you say you're an editor
what do you what do you do yourself here
technical director technical eric what
do you do yourself
social media guy what do you do yourself
researcher social media okay so that's
four different right five six seven so
there's seven
research you got like five jobs you
don't have one job right you have a lot
of jobs that you do
but there's there's been many jobs what
do you think that numbers last 200 years
it would have to be in the thousands
it's a crazy number
do you want to guess are you afraid no i
mean i haven't 200 years
yeah it's a bit of a hundred thousand
three billion jobs three billion
different jobs three billion occupations
occupations
types of jobs yes three billion
different ways
to make money i mean they're used i mean
the railroads had to get built so there
were a million you know a little
that's the occupation's best billion
different
as well of jobs so he's sitting here
and by the way just so you know he's a
team bill gates vaccine
okay he's a team 100 of people in the
world got to take a vaccine
he's a team trump is uh you know not the
brightest guy in the world
he's a team i'm just giving you the team
he's he's a part of he's not the team up
and then he still says look i'm telling
you right now
human mankind if it's created three
billion jobs the last 200 years
it's going to create many more jobs so
man
well man we have to be creative
to see how we can increase our market
value
that's what we got to do and you know
what there's no borders
anymore that's there's a wall though we
are building a wall
well i'm not going there
not going there but there are no borders
the wall is going to keep the corona you
want
if you want the best editor in the world
i mean
that's another thing that coronavirus is
taught he's right there
or he might be 3000 miles away or he
might be halfway around the world
the same situation applies to u.s
workers
you can be found i mean there are people
who've got hundreds
of entire workforces in india and
you know highly productive what's to say
that
that we cannot be the next generation
but again
workers i think are border free at this
point
you can be anywhere in the world and
work for anyone in the world
in the world of tomorrow i i totally
agree you know how i kind of learn about
that when we started creating content i
didn't think much about them like let me
just create content
and i got an email from a guy in lagos
i'm like
huh i don't know anybody in logos i just
want you and i follow your content
like we don't have that many subscribers
we got a couple hundred subscribers
you watch my content okay my mother
doesn't watch my content you watch my
content's pretty impressive right
then all of a sudden we started seeing
more then all of a sudden you're walking
in the airport and uk guy stops you
then we're in perth croatia out of all
the places
and i'm having a coffee this husband and
wife is going crazy
like we're not that big yet right
then all of a sudden we put a vault
conference together last year a year and
a half ago whatever the time year and a
half ago
people show up from uh uh i don't know
what the countries was 42 different
countries they showed up 42 different
you flew all the way from philippines i
had no idea
then philippines comes out with an
article saying the top
entrepreneurs in the world to follow
entrepreneur magazine philippines i was
ranked ahead of oprah winfrey in
philippines i've never been to
philippines
never been to philippines but on that
list this
the market is changed fully with social
media
if you want to be able to make money if
you want to be able to change your life
if you want to be able to do any of that
stuff
if there's ever been a time for you to
be able to do it it's today to do it we
have three different stories at this
table
okay everybody at this table is doing
okay
you you you had a way to turn around
your story with what you grew up to what
you ended up doing
you were going to comedian rod party
right all this other stuff all of a
sudden one day you're like listen i'm
going to get serious about business
you're going to life settlement change
your business boom
look where you are right now you get to
do whatever you're living a dream is
what i told you yesterday
you know you're able to come in i'm here
with ddb yeah
you know you know you have your story of
where you're at right now tv
people know the name you're an expert
nine years federal reserve you've done
all this other stuff
billionaires subscribed to your company
started at
community college how awesome is that
wow so so the
the point is you know you matt didn't
even graduate from community college he
got kicked out he's a hacker
it was definitely i gotta tell you i got
vpn on my phone and on my laptop
you cannot have my password that's a
shout out for vpn expressvpn
but by the way if you're watching this
and you're enjoying this we're in the
first half of the
uh a podcast here put a thumbs up and
share this
and comment below if you're watching
this we're going to keep going uh to the
second half of this so let's talk about
a little bit about
home sales i know you briefly touched up
on it if you don't mind going a little
bit deeper into it
pending home sales hits record high in
august keyword
pending pending home sales the national
association of realtors pending home
sales index serves 8.8
last month on an all-time high of 132.8
signaling the u.s housing market rally
continued into the fall
economists surveyed by bloomberg expect
an increase
of 3.1 what is
happening in real estate well so you
have
a once in a lifetime situation here
right
think about where we were a year ago if
you were hip
if you were a millennial you want it to
be in the urban center
you wanted to be in a high rise you you
were wondering why there weren't enough
grocery stores and things to serve you
if you're
living living the life downtown
all of these think about the cranes
throughout america
all what the cranes have been building
big high-rise office buildings big
high-rise apartments
that has been flipped on its head so i
mean
and all over my twitter feed are people
leaving california and moving to prosper
and moving to south lake and
that they've discovered you know life in
texas
but but we have a mass exodus right now
i have friends
outside of new york city in westchester
county that have been trying to sell
their house for two years
and they took it off the market when
they saw how white hot
that house and how quickly housing was
heating up as people were leaving new
york city
and they're like i'm i'm taking my house
off the market i'm going to wait until
prices get where i really want them to
be and they were smart and then they got
the price that they wanted
that is the fundamental driver behind
that is jay powell and his happy
printing press and the federal reserve
buying up
mortgage-backed securities forcing
30-year conventional mortgage rates down
to record lows
so then that then does the question make
up is it fake or is it real
is this fake is this fake growth it is
it is not the same growth that you think
that it is because
lenders are you're starting to hear
anecdotes from real estate
agents i got the offer i got the buyer
the seller accepted the bank turned them
down
so lending standards are coming down if
you talk about capital one
synchrony jp morgan credit card lines
are being cut
because remember right now you have 12
months of forbearance
forbearance means that you do not have
to pay your mortgage for 12 months
through march of 2021.
so i mean if you're if you're the lender
you're not happy at all
or if you're a landlord in america
but from the perspective of we're in
64 of americans think that the economy
is worse today than it was a year ago
you look at the housing market and
you're like the housing market begs to
differ
well that's easy enough when 15 of fha
loans and fha loans are the ones that
you get three and a half percent
down payments on and that business is
blowing up it's huge it's white hot but
of those loans are delinquent but the
banks can't foreclose
so you've got buyers buying into a white
white white hot market
but a lot of it is being engineered and
fabricated
so i'm a big fan of renting right so i'm
i'm that person that lives in the center
of downtown miami like i don't even have
a car
i'm not looking to move into the suburbs
that was my life in new york okay so you
understand that most of my friends in
new york
obviously if you live in l.a you're
driving all of our pets i went with pat
in l.a we're driving over every
different
different city it's hard to do that in
l.a living in a city center
but if you're living in downtown chicago
downtown boston
downtown miami even in dallas over here
you know i'm a fan of renting so i mean
i actually did an episode where
44 of homeowners regret being a
homeowner and
63 of millennials regret being a
homeowner so people are seeing these
super super super low interest rates
versus what they were 10 20 30 years ago
when interest rates were double digits
and people say of course i need to get
into the housing market of course i need
to refinance
of course i need to do this the tiny box
of what the payment is
that's all they're looking at and you're
saying that it could end ugly
i'm saying that a lot of especially a
lot of
of the first-time home buyers who are
getting into the market they don't
they don't understand that they're that
that home prices have never been this
high in the history of mankind
they don't know that they're buying in
at the top of the market home prices
have
been as high and interest rates have
never been this low correct so what's
the what's the what's that
uh that's the correlation yeah when
interest rates are low home prices are
high we're interested and yet you're
hearing the national association of
realtors say
well pricing's becoming an issue even
with interest rates as low as they are
even with mortgages
that's the part when it becomes scary
look you know it is
you're a bodybuilder when you no longer
are growing
and you're doing every single steroids
and growth hormone in the body there's a
problem there
that's that's right paul schreiner
that's what's going on
that's kind of what's going on today
meaning
you're doing every single thing to get
the economy and real estate going and
it's still
barely hanging on and powell comes out
saying they're going to keep the
interest rates at zero until 2020
forever until 2023 wow it's a scary car
in his press conference he said that
they kept interest rates at zero for
seven years last time and nothing bad
happened
well no nothing bad happened because he
came and printed more so
i mean look we're talking about another
two trillion dollars of
stimulus but if again if you're throwing
good money after bad
and you're not getting anything for it
all you're gonna do
is four months from now we're going to
be talking about the next stimulus
package
and how big it's going to be can i ask
you a question i just cause you worked
with the dallas fed
right so i kind of want to get your
opinion we've got um
jerome powell right now we're on the fed
prior to him we had janet yellen
proud of that it was bernanke that
was my uncle alan greenspan right so
who do you think did a good job who's
doing a horrible job who do you agree
with who do you disagree with what are
your thoughts on just the fed overall
you got to go back one more you got to
go back to paul volcker paul my guy okay
tell me why
because he he didn't care what the stock
market did
he cared about the economy and making
sure that
monetary policy was designed so that the
u.s economy could be resilient
alan greenspan came in and a few days
into office the stock market crashes in
he's got an obsession self-admitted
obsession with the stock market
so he starts to manipulate the market so
that no matter what happens
prices don't fall but that's not life
life
is you take risks and there are
consequences
but you've had four people in a row
greens starting with greenspan bernanke
yellow now powell
who are trying to make sure that they
just hold it together but
how much better off would we be if one
in every five
u.s companies was not what we call a
zombie
it's like knight of the walking dead one
in five u.s companies
and they're being kept alive but just
based on
free money being out there do you want
these companies to fail these big
companies
i do you know what and next next year's
innovators want these companies to fail
because if you don't take the bad
capacity out of the system there's no
room for the new entrance that's how you
get regenerative growth
is you get the people who are badass
business workers
you fully agree you have to do that and
we've now we've got one in five u.s
companies
who are just they don't have they don't
make enough money
to cover what they have to spend to
cover their interest on the debt they
have
that's what a zombie is it's pretty
simple what say you pbd i totally agree
with her i mean it's that simple you you
have to have these big guys this
too big to fill is typically how many
companies is it seven of them it's
five to seven names they say the major
banks are saying no no no no no we're
talking about
it under too big to fail like they'll
say there's these seven companies that
are too big to fail we cannot let them
fail right and they'll talk about that
and it's typically five seven companies
and they'll say oh this company is
officially added in the list of
too big to fail companies right we
cannot prevent them from going out of
business
and it's worse than it was and more
concentrated than it was going into
other than those top seven as you say
yeah if you're just a massive company
and you are a zombie company as danielle
refers to if you're missing fail if
you're not
of course your ship's failed yeah of
course that's what capitalism is right
remember the freedom to buy the freedom
to sell
the freedom to try the freedom to fail
okay
that's the system that's capitalism
freedom to buy you have the freedom to
buy whatever you want to buy
you have the freedom to sell sell
whatever you want to sell you have the
freedom to try
go for it try something but you also
should have the freedom
to fail we've taken the fourth one out
that's a big problem it's a huge problem
you got to be able to fail if every
single time
i'm playing offense and you're not
letting me fail
i'm spoiled like if if you have a kid
you know how you see your father builds
his son out every
single time yeah of course he bails him
out at 16 then he has to bail him out at
then 22 then 24 then 33 then 39 then 48
and 52 you didn't build a leader you
build a dependent person
these two big to fail companies are now
dependent on the government to
constantly bail them out
it's not good for the economy that's not
capitalism by the way just so you know
that it's not
that is not that's called crony that's
when the yeah that's when the people
come out against capitalism and i'm with
them i actually agree with them because
while you're letting these companies
that can just go around throwing out
around throwing around their weight
because they're needed
what companies come to my like what bear
stearns obviously folded during 2008
right
bear stearns was clearly not too big to
fail right what companies should have
failed this time around some cruise
lines
some air airline companies what other
companies should have failed this time
around
it's not look i understand the whole
argument that the airlines are a
national need and it's a matter of
national security
i get that but when you spend 96
of the money that you make on share
buybacks and then you have to go to the
government for a handout
and and when you when when you're up
late at night
you know throwing threats out there
we're going to fire everybody if we
don't get the stimulus tomorrow when
you're putting the feet to the fire
of the politicians and the taxpayers of
the united states by the way
and you paid yourself all the bonuses
and you've got your vacation homes and
you're not missing a meal
at all but yet you're you're holding
other people hostage
because you didn't run your business
efficiently enough to plan for a rainy
day
by the way delta cleanest balance sheet
in the country
they haven't had to push through with
layoffs because they didn't take too
much debt on
and they're a different story and so why
why don't we reward the companies
that plan to survive whether there's a
bump in the economy or not
as opposed to rewarding the companies
that can only survive
if everything's going perfectly and when
then when the peanut butter hits the fan
then we have to go bail them out
everything's incentive everything is
incentive system the way you
had a couple parents spend some time
with me this weekend they asked me how
do you get your kids to read
and i said it's very simple they just
watched everything that happened so
dylan it's his birthday
he got 50 gifts just because you got 50
years you don't play with all the 50
gifts not in the bed david household
and one of the guys got him some lego i
didn't say anything dylan came up
daddy look how cool this lego is i said
dude that's sick
it says so how many books do i have to
read for this i said what do you think
let's negotiate
wow he says it's smaller than the other
one i said i agree how about we make
this one eight
i said i'm okay with that so i do eight
then we go
build it together no problem dad can you
put it up there so i can see it i put
all the stuff i buy for them at the top
so they can see they can't reach it
but they can see what their toys are no
problem the couple that's sitting next
to me they're like an incentive
wow i didn't even say anything he came
right he
we shared the excitement we made a
negotiation
he knew he had to earn it to play the
lego he came up with the number eight
i put up the incentive as a compensation
structure for him to see it now he's got
to go readers in the
today's compensation structure is hey
too big to fail
whether you screw up or not don't worry
about it let's open the lego right now
what are we doing what are we doing but
then he knows how to he knows how to
behave
in the corporate world and and not sit
there and be like
i'm on my facebook time you're like no
you're working
you guys remember that video i did with
the breaking the tv thing i got to give
a shout out to my daughter this is a
very special moment santa if you ever
watch this
i want you to know how i handle this
with you so
uh uh uh so you have to teach these kids
that they can't break things and there's
different systems on how to do it so
we did this video you did you did show
so i got to show you this this video
that's about to tell
yeah so this video that we go and we
break the tv to say hey your next five
moves paul yeah it's pretty
it's pretty uh uh intense video that we
we made
anyway so you know so i go on they see
the tv
so you know this weekend she's got
family over
and uh she's spending time with her you
know
peers and all this stuff and i see her
grabbing the xbox remote and she just
tapping the tv i just bought this tv
it's an 85 inch screen tv she's tapping
the tv tapping a tv tap on the tv and
she's smiling
and then all of a sudden she has one big
smile and she really smiles by the way
this was a
uh uh uh what is this the one this is
yeah this is the one
so watch this here okay so she
shouldn't have seen this video okay now
that's her daddy doing it it's a
marketing video we made you can pause it
kai oh i thought that's what you did if
they played too much xbox no
no no this was because you don't read
eight books this is what happens
this was because paul was watching one
too many uh uh
videos late at night on his phone okay
and not netflix so
anyways that's a whole different story
okay that's a that's a very sweet shout
out to you paul we love you baby you're
amazing
so anyways anyways so this is obviously
josh was this is marketing idea to do
something like this so we did this video
and then uh uh so senna is sitting there
and he's
hitting uh she's hitting the tv i don't
think anything about it because we're
not watching that tv that night
the next week two weeks later like just
yesterday the next day we turned on the
tv and
and cmx like what is that on the tv i'm
like what's what
why is there a big circle on there like
what is that circle
i'm like guys who did that and i'm
looking around to see all the kids where
they are
tico's not moving dylan's not moving
santa's hiding under the couch
alexander what are you doing down there
and she's hiding like
oh my gosh i said come on we got to go
talk so she comes out we go to the
living bedroom i said why'd you do that
so you realize
if you do that and i'm not going to
replace the tv for a while because i
want them to see
to complain about the fact that they
don't like
how it looks the tv is not getting
replaced for some time it's gonna sit
just i can bite
you know it go you can afford another tv
but it's gonna sit right there for them
to kind of see
okay you want to break the tv next time
here's what happens then i said santa
what's your favorite toy
and this is a shout out to tigran i said
what's your favorite toy she says
uh uh elsa i said go grab your elsa toy
so we took the elsa toy and we threw it
away oh
now i grabbed it i put it on a bag when
she sees this i have it i'm gonna give
it to her six months but i put in a
drawer
i kept it and i said if you show me that
you can take care of the stuff that we
have in our house
i'll buy you a bigger elsa toy but if
you can't take care of the stuff that we
have in our house that we work very hard
for i'm not going to buy it for you
and i said how does it feel right now
you lost the elsa not good
i said the same feels that we want to
work hard for this tv it doesn't feel
good
you have to take care of yourself are
you going to work on that stuff yes i am
so every time she watches the tv and
dylan says
why is there that sea hole on the tv
sent a ghost
but you know the point is this our
parents did certain things like this to
us for us to realize what you have to do
i think uh i think we got to do the same
thing to some of these too big to fail
companies
they got to feel a little bit of the
pain we can't just print mike and hey
listen can you give me another couple
hundred billion dollars
can you give me five billion that's all
i'm asking for just give me another five
billion dollars yeah you can't do that
too often so
since you talked about airlines let's
talk about this 30 000 airline jobs
hang in the balance as lawmakers debate
airlines agreed last spring not to lay
off or for long
for low any workers until october 1st as
any condition
as a condition of a 25 billion infusion
of federal aid
now bearing a last-minute agreement on
how much to spend
on a pandemic relief package for the
country nearly
50 000 airline workers are set to be
furloughed
thursday right and pelosi goes back
they're going back and forth she's
asking for the 2.2 trillion dollars
there was a little bit of a pushback
yesterday so they came back nothing was
finalized uh
american airlines group has warned that
furloughs of 19 000 employees will start
when exit
when existing u.s payroll support runs
out at the end of the day
wednesday oh they announced it united
airlines holdings
said earlier this week that it was
planning to cut 12 000 jobs
and smaller carriers are set to make
additional reductions as well so the
layoffs could cap job losses already
total 150
000 at the nation's four largest
carriers
based on employees who have left
voluntarily or taken temporarily so
what's going on with the airline are we
recovering
by the way kai before she responds can
you pull up the tsa
flight sheet to see how many people are
traveling on daily basis but go ahead go
ahead uh danielle
so um we are not and
i tell you why didn't you just say zoom
was the second
number two right yes company in the
third quarter
uh first 88 okay zoom um
if you talk to ceos across the country
they know how to find their zoom
and they know how consultants and
businesses and conferences and meetings
they've already seen in their p l's
they've already seen
in their budgets what their budgets look
like
without travel and they're like wow this
is going straight to the bottom line
and i've got these people on a zoom call
doing what i used to spend
put the person in first class in
business class put them up in a nice
hotel for a week
and then flying back home to the family
on the weekends
that business is not coming back for a
while it's not coming back for a good
long time
the second the second element is
international travels
not coming back for a long time
and i think carriers worldwide have told
you that
so can you profitably exist on leisure
travel on the most cost cost conscious
flyers
the answer is no so then why are we
giving them more money
if it's going to be a reduced footprint
for some time because
we are evolving to a new type of
technology such that we
don't have to get on an airplane to meet
with somebody halfway across the country
or halfway around the world
if that's the case then companies might
not ever
go back to having huge travel budgets
like they had before so i mean that is
something that that should be factored
into
what politicians are discussing right
now because
in three or four months time when the
next expiration comes
and they're they're saying now we're
going to fire them and you say well is
has business travel come back no
so is it going to be another 25 trillion
25 billion
so that's that's the question let me ask
you this is our
is the airline industry the next
newspaper
no no no no it people will still want to
go places
and you know the next supersonic jet is
the next technology the next generation
of air travel is in the works
it is but it's going to be this is like
this is like new york real estate yeah
it's going to be a long time
what's a long time what's a long time
decade i don't know that it's going to
be decades
i don't know that we'll ever go back to
where we were before yeah ever
and i don't think that the footprint
will ever need to be as
big as it is i don't think capacity is
the bigger layoffs we're seeing
is with aircraft manufacturers i mean
look three to four percent ebitda
you're not dealing with big margins so
and everybody keeps saying oh our
flights are cheaper our flights are
cheaper our flights are cheaper our
flights are cheaper flights are cheaper
no flights not service right that's why
i'm saying the leisure the leisure
traveler
is not where the margins used to be it
was the guy in first class
who was like i've i'm cone shares key at
american airlines i'm
a total road road warrior i live to fly
that's not coming back anytime soon i i
kind of don't disagree by the way that's
that's what's uh
uh weird if you look at this here this
is daily travel right this is on the tsa
side
on how many travelers we had on 9 30
versus how many travelers we had a year
ago in 2019 look at that 6 34 was
yesterday
last year same exact day 2 million 82
right let's see what's the highest
number we cracked
did we crack a million at all so i see
873 right there let's see if there's a
number bigger than 870 labor day
labor day was pretty keep going 9 35
okay 9 35
9 68 that's labor day that's right keep
going higher keep going keep going keep
going keep going and then july 4th was
the other was the other peak
let's see what the other one is go to
july 4th so 9
60 i don't see any 800's for a while and
then july 4th 466
7 18 okay so 9 168 cracked a million
no we have not cracked a million so but
here's here's the other part
i really enjoyed this conversation with
pablo solman this hacker guy you know
we talked about the virus okay we talk
about the virus we have a lot of things
he has the cure
he knows he said he says look i know
exactly how to prevent hurricanes from
happening and i said then how come
there's no
how come we're not stopping this is
because there's not a business model for
it so what do you mean there's not a
business model for wouldn't some
governments
give some money to be able he says pat
we know how to prevent a hurricane from
happening
i said if you know how to prevent a
hurricane from happening do you have a
way of
creating hurricanes he starts laughing
he said yes we also know how to create a
hurricane
i said okay how about fires how come we
can't put the fires out his answer was
some of these fires we need it's
actually good that we're having some
fires some of these fires when i say
california is having way too many of
them
he says we have the technology but
there's not a business model for it as
if the
smartest people live in california how
come we can't fix that but we went to
the vaccine
he gave a very interesting answer and
again remember this guy's the guy that
wants everybody to be vaccinated because
he thinks that's the solution and he
thinks people who think
vaccines are bad have issues that's
really what this guy thought you have
issues if you don't take the vaccine
so i'm giving you to know who he is with
his positions before i tell you what he
said
he said one one of the things that uh we
made a mistake with is
modern day travel i said what do you
mean he says we travel way too much
he said we travel way too much he says
that's one of the reasons why
i said what can we do to prevent the
next coronavirus or next stars or ebola
from happening
he says we need to minimize modern day
travel international travel is way too
much
think about this think about this whole
concept of what airlines are going
through today because
when you go on a flight like even myself
i'm on a flight a few months back i'm
going to palm springs to have a meeting
with nlg i don't know when it was maybe
it was february or january to go to
their strategy session that they're
having
at palm desert ritz carlton so we go and
i'm sitting first class next to this guy
he's uh
telling me about his uh husband and how
they've been together for 28 years
french guy
and this is january okay this is january
so he takes out his wipe and he starts
wiping the seat
i'm like oh my gosh what a well you're
one of those guys this guy's got a freak
so he starts wiping his handle
he starts wiping the middle and he says
here you go wipe your seat
i'm like oh i'm good i'm just trust me
wipe your site start i'm like oh
now i look like one of these guys that's
wiping says i always want and he's
teaching me
i always wipe the screen because you're
going to touch the screen wipe the
screen
wipe this so he's teaching me everything
to wipe he says you also have to wipe
this thing that you bring up you know
first class to put your
he says wipe this so he says here's some
hand sanitizer i'm like at this point of
the game i'm like this is a little too
much
this is free corona pretty correct so
he's giving me all this stuff so i'm
like i'm finally doing it i'm like i'm
kind of like doing it just to
accommodate and we ended up having a
three hour straight conversation
incredible conversation we stayed in
contact
really cool guy we took shots we joked
around he's worked in iran at a hotel we
had a very good time together
anyways when we get off the fight
jenna's looking at me saying
why are you guys hugging each other oh
my gosh it's my new friend we had the
most ridiculous
full-blown gay 28 years married and we
laughed the entire
flight to palm springs right
now when i get on flights i take out the
spring
i'm doing this right i'm doing the white
i'm doing
everything this guy did yep and i'm
telling you for anybody that knows me
you would have never seen me doing the
wipes and all this other stuff right
well like listen it's going to be all
right when you see how quickly they turn
when you see how quickly they turn
planes around
there's no way to clean them i agree but
the point i'm trying to make to you is
man how long is it going to take for us
for people to try like let's just say
you were doing business in china
you're going to take that travel you can
take that flight back to china i don't
know let's just say you were running
biz dev in china you're gonna fly to you
think you think out of the millions of
people that would travel are getting the
100 a million people are comfortably
going to be willing to travel back to
china
and i don't know about that i think
there's going to be some things taking
place
maybe last year i went to australia
though and i
i would go back and there is free covert
though yes
but there is technology out there there
is uv technology out there
there are entrepreneurs right now who
are figuring out how to zap buildings
and how to zap
airplanes and make it quick and
efficient and
just there are zappers out there it's
not it's not so much that you have to
clean surfaces with liquids the
technology exists
in in uv to make the germs go away and
do it efficiently and do it it doesn't
the scale doesn't exist yet
but it's coming get that asap they need
to get that ac but it's coming
i promise i mean i hope it's coming fast
you know i hope they get it very quickly
because
those guys if they don't that industry
is not looking too pretty if they if
they don't figure out a solution fairly
quickly
i really believe it's going to be
problematic for the airline industry for
some time by the way
did you have any opinions on the on the
uh trump tax returns or no did you
the 750 are there anything you're pretty
reasonable when it comes out to things
like this
um you know i look he he clearly
his tax returns might have been
that of any other real estate developer
on steroids
there are definitely some questionable
expenses that he has taken
and the only thing i don't uh that i
don't think has been established is
whether or not
the the statute of limitations on irs
audits
is paused and whether or not a standing
president
can be audited or whether or not that
situation goes into a holding pattern as
long as he's in
office so i mean the the biggest thing
at issue is
the 72.9 million dollar refund that he
got
only by way of legislation that obama
signed into law that
changed the tax law that allowed him to
go further back in time
three more years two and a half more
years and club club claw forward
former losses that had no value prior to
that
but i think that if there was a smoking
gun i think we would have seen it by now
yeah i agree i agree and the reality of
it is
no one's seen the return so no one
really knows what's going on and this
whole tax return thing the first person
that did the tax return was it nixon
is nixon the first person that started
showing tax returns because prior to i
think fdr did a little bit but then
no no i think you're right i think
you're right about yeah nick nixon was
the first one yeah fdr they found
the fact that he had stocks and nazi
owned companies and all that stuff
that's the stuff that came back during
the
fcr side he also increased the taxes but
then it was
uh it was found that was
unconstitutional for him
or for the president's taxes to increase
so he
he was like a hypocrite in the sense
that he was saying oh pay more taxes
but not himself he went to congress and
they lowered the taxes who is he fdr
yeah you know so so this whole you but
you realize president doesn't have to
show their tax return it's not like
mandatory for them to show
tax returns when john kerry did his
returns he showed his full return
but his wife's the rich one in the
family the highest she showed partially
ketchup yeah yeah well but i mean look
seventy thousand dollar deductions for
haircuts paying ivanka consulting fees
there are definitely um
you let's put it this way it was not
presidential how he treated the u.s tax
code by playing fast and loose
but did he break a law i think if he'd
broken a law we would know it by now
if he wasn't president i don't think any
would be complaining if it was just
donald trump the real estate mogul
people be like you know donny do what
donny do he is what he is right no i
mean the real
issue is president yeah there are people
are questioning and there are reasons
that the district attorney in manhattan
um is going to get
uh the returns and there are certain
deutsche bank
loans that are in question and there are
there there are entities where he didn't
fully extricate himself and yet he took
advantage of laws as if he had
there are some questionable things um
but again
i don't think that with the standing
president that anything can be done
do you think did he thank obama on the
debate it was probably with a little
circle i don't know if he did
during the debate but no during the
debate he said something about uh
thank you obama because of you yeah
classic you know yeah but he's right i
actually should be thinking obama it's
the only reason he's got him he'll get
70 million dollars obama helped the rich
get richer
yeah obama helped the rich kid he really
did obama helped the rich get richer and
he bailed out a lot of people
obama's a capitalist come on guys
obama's good for the rich people obama's
a
uh he would be falling under the crony
side though because he helped out the
bigger guys
that's what he did he helped out the
bigger guy he did and i think that
that's that's
you know people think that you know the
democrats are for the people and the
republicans or for
commerce rich people yeah no no i mean
if you look back at fannie and freddie
who got bailed out by the us government
you know the third
largest political contributions were
made to obama
so um and by the way who ran up our debt
at a really fast pace quietly quietly
while the federal reserve had interest
rates at zero
but you know he's speaking to daniel uh
that danielle because this is you know
i'm intrigued by your mindset here
you ever see the the u.s debt clock this
year yes yes yes yes yes it is
like with all the green and the red and
the red and the green twenties you guys
have not seen this u.s debt clock
yeah kai pull this up go ahead 27 plus
trillion this is scary stuff
almost 27 trillion okay so like one of
the i i i get
like i don't play video games but this
is my definition of a video game i go in
there and i watch all these numbers
coming in debt per person u.s gdp bing
bing bing so if you can go to the debt
time the debt clock time machine right
so and you can top right there you go
kyle you're doing great today
and you can fast forward four years or
go back four years so kai what i want
you to do
is let's go back to 2008 right
pre-recession
10 10 true 10 trillion yeah is that 10
trillion happy holidays we should end
the year around 30.
okay so think about that so now go back
to where it is now go to 2016.
that's what you want to do wait let's go
eat right here let's go 2016
2016 20 double okay boom now that's my
point it was the quietest
widening of the social safety net in u.s
history since fdr was in office
i'm not this isn't a political point
going somewhere this is not a political
point this is a monetary point
kai keep going 20 20 now we're at 26. so
we went from 10
to 20 to 26. go four years from now kai
now we're at 47. so when so okay
who the hell came up with 47 that's just
based on social security spending
medicare spending entitlements the baby
boomers not gonna
go from it's not gonna go from 27 to 47
trillion dollars i mean
whoever okay so all right wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute donald j
trump signed socialism into law how do
you put that genie back in the box
i i agree what do you mean that's the
stimulus
stimulus that's socialism of course
there was the
there was the alternative to do
infrastructure spending you're looking
at me like i wanted it
you're saying we should have not had any
stimulus packages no it's not that
i'm just saying we couldn't we could
have we could have spent the money of
the country
more smartly right now look how many men
since the cares act just passed since
march so it's been six months yeah
okay so how many americans would be at
work right now had we
done infrastructure spending as part of
that bill
how many 10 million yeah no
probably not 10 million but a lot more
would be at work right now
than they are and and but when you start
getting people back when you sign
socialism into law when you pay people
to not work they get used to it and they
like it
which means that you get to keep that
means that 47 is is conservative
kai once you bring you think that's a
conservative clock if we're going to be
if if if
what did we just talk about we just
talked about industries not coming back
right so if that is accurate even
slightly accurate the u.s debt clock
whether it's 30 trillion or 20 27
trillion or
40 trillion what does that do to america
well i tell you this crazy amount of
debt what is that again
whether that's off by a few trillion or
not most americans have grown up with
falling
interest rates everybody knows deflation
deflation deflation
the cost of my tv is just cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper what's gotten more
expensive your iphone
but but the cost of a lot of things have
decreased over
a factor of time you want to run the
debt up that much we're going to
we're going to figure out what inflation
was which is before you were born
what do you think pat about what just
just these numbers
nothing none of this stuff excites me
i'm not for it
in oh wait we should have let the guys
go out of business it should have been
okay
the only guy that paid back shout out to
bob ben moshe who died
aig ceo that came back from met life he
was on his deathbed
living at dubrovnik croatia and i we did
business with him for many years we were
his top iowa writings
i love he we would sit in the meeting he
says let me tell you guys what happened
the other day i called my mother-in-law
and i take my mother-in-law out to
dinner all the time when i went to
dinner my mother-in-law my mother-in-law
said
bob why don't you get back with my
daughter he says
women don't you understand i like you i
don't like your daughter right
now that's what the leadership didn't
exist that's how he was to the
mother-in-law oh my gosh
he's phenomenal by the way i think when
he died but both his ex-wife and his
girlfriend were there
holding his hands when he died that's
the way to go you got to respect that
part right then when you got that kind
of uh
when you're able to win the left and the
right i mean he would have been a great
moderator
so tell me about it that's a centrist
yeah that's just interest for you so
when it comes down to the guy they got
183 billion dollars i had dinner with
him in a cfo one time david herzog david
herzog
is a guy that went from being a cfo i
think he was a ceo cfo
american general to becoming the cfo of
aig they went to the government got a
183 billion dollar
line they paid it back within five six
years with 21 billion dollars of
interest and jim is still
trying to pay back the debt so you got
to respect what these guys did at aig
but
that's not everybody it's not everybody
everybody else kept their money
everybody kind of stuck around and they
did their money
a cool story about bob and moshe when he
when they aig brought him to save him
and they said so bob we really need you
and we think you're the right guy to do
it
he says okay well this is my ask he puts
the number
they said you want us to pay you 10
million a year he says
yes i'm like a prostitute i can be bot
i'm just an expensive prostitute
they faked him as 10 million and he
saved aig
bob is a unique type of guy man when he
died on on the night he did it was our
award ceremony it was a
mark peterson one of our friends came up
and we had a very interesting moment
because
you know i love that guy bob wasn't my
kind of a guy so this year
if we keep giving the money out what
happens the problem here is the fact
that now the left doesn't have an
argument against trump
because if trump wouldn't have done this
they would have said if we were in house
we would have given you the money so he
did so sorry but
when did sanders drop out after the
cares act i mean it's like okay
what am i going to do
but can we bring up one topic real quick
what about the new stimulus deal i
assume you're not for
anything are you for anything where are
we at with this new stimulus plan
this remake heroes act part two the
heels act where we at with that again
you you have an intractable problem
because
a few months ago you had 26 30 million
americans collecting unemployment
insurance you got the same thing now
it is not productive to continually just
throw money
at people so no more stimulus that's the
agreement
we're done but the problem is because
of what has not been done in terms of
making productive investments as a
government
is you're going to have a homeless
crisis overnight
look what's going on in l.a i mean i
have a homeless crisis overnight but
when you think of all the people who
cannot afford to pay their bills right
now
so what do you do if if people can't pay
their bills there's covet going on
they're homeless you have to do
something about the problem you can't
just be like yo
you're too small to fail by the way this
is the formula if you want to go into
socialism
this is the formula keep giving free
money and then
have a guy stop giving free money then
he goes from being robin hood to being
the worst most hated man on earth
worldwide
that's what happens to the guy that's
what's about to happen to him if he
doesn't sign the next stimulus
oh talk about a story they're gonna show
homelessness
and they're gonna it's called the
hegelian dialectic which means create a
problem
but don't do it create a problem okay
then blame somebody for it then the
person that created a problem
come out and say i'm here to save you
yeah that's what's happening right now
create a problem homelessness find
somebody to point a finger and blame it
which is trump
and then come back and say that's why
you need us if we were here you wouldn't
have been homeless
arsonist and firefighters have been
amazing it would have been so good for
you
we are your heroes oh my gosh newsom we
love you so much and then bone
all this other stuff happens it's a very
simple formula it's a very
uh formula that's been around for a long
long time that's being used today so do
you think mnuchin actually wants to cut
a deal
oh yeah i do you think he does look
there's something else going on here so
what's going on
it's it's a little bit wonky but what we
call
quantitative easing what people think of
as money printing
requires a product jay powell has to
have something to buy
in order to keep the stock market
levitated he needs treasury issuance he
needs fresh
debt created so that he can buy it up
and grow the fed's balance sheet which
transmissions itself back
recycles itself back into the stock
market and that's why
as the feds as the growth of the fed's
balance sheet has been tapering off in
recent weeks
we've seen a little bit of wobbliness in
the markets the markets have gone to the
moon the last 72 hours
on the hopes of this stimulus because
jay pal is going to have more product to
buy
if he's got 2 trillion more dollars of
treasuries out there
then the fed's balance sheet can go from
7 trillion to 9 trillion
and he'll buy it all and that trump
knows and if you want to know why pelosi
doesn't want
to do the stimulus and why she's pushing
back as much as she is
it's because she knows that the one
thing that can that
that the best thing to get him
re-elected is that stocks are at
all-time highs on november the third if
they do the stimulus tax will be at an
all-time high
yeah okay i tell you the second half
second half of trump he doesn't have to
get reelected
everything he wanted to do he's gonna do
in the second half good bad ugly all of
it
that's it obamacare finishing up the
wall
going after the clintons going after
everything he's gonna do on the second
term
everything good bad ugly because he
doesn't and by the way rates are going
to go up
rates are going to go up the market's
not going to be as high market's going
to take a little bit of a hit you're
going to see all that stuff happen on
the second term
shout out to danielle we're making
wonkiness
go let's go to the the real dead clock
because these people know
new york city climate change clock in
new york city counts down to global
deadline
did you guys know we only have seven
years 103 days
15 hours and 24 minutes left to live
that's the climate change debt clock are
you worried or no guys we got to go home
i say we go we go we go like have a
couple shots
i just got a nice bottle of wine from a
friend artem who's got a book coming up
i don't know what it is told me it's a
good bottle of wine we drink a bottle of
wine we go party maybe we go to vegas
for the last seven years that's left
what are we doing working here
seriously why am i working if we know
the end of the world is coming
don't you worry about this where do you
see yourself seven years from now pat
i mean frozen or burnt
cryogenics cry i'll show you for taking
miles
i'll freeze you i'm either going to be
frozen
it went through my head you just
offended santa in her community
guys you have her doll hidden held high
i just
told you what happens when you when you
draw hide elsa
elsa's hidden she's gonna make it i'm
gonna cryogenic you dad do you have an
opinion on this on this uh on this
question on the climate change that uh
that cloud
you have you seen the social dilemma
no but i've heard good things oh
gee i mean tell me about it it's got
the guy from facebook who invented the
like button he's like
it was supposed to be something that
spread happiness and joy
and all of a sudden now it's something
for teenagers and teenage girls to judge
themselves by whether they have
this many likes or not so but all
insiders
all whistleblowers all people who they
their lives are set
they've got plenty of money to live for
the rest of their lives they had
absolutely no reason to do this
and they've all come out and whether
it's climate change
they went through a scene in in in this
huge documentary that is revolutionary i
recommend everybody watch it's called
the gun
the the social dilemma in the comment
section so people can go to it
i watched i watched it with my twins and
my twins were like their mouths were
open i mean
they're almost 13 year olds totally
engaged
they went and they did what is climate
change
in in a google search so they did it on
the west coast
in the middle of the country and on the
east coast and the first thing that
pulls up
is different depending on where you are
if you're
on the left coast and you pull up
climate change it'll say climate change
is an existential disaster
if you're smack in the middle of trump
country in the middle
of the in the midwest and you pull up
climate change the first thing that
google shows you
knowing where you are is is a hoax
climate change is a hoax you go over to
the east coast
again you get back to climate change is
going to destroy the planet
but it depended and you know if you're
in the deep south again
wow so but that is how that's why things
like this
i see differently because you know that
somebody with an agenda is manipulating
you
and that that's why i think the onus is
on
enjoy social media exploit social media
use social media to get ahead
but you got to do your own damn homework
you do because everybody's got an agenda
and social media is a really effective
and efficient way
to put to to push your what your
thoughts and your views whether they're
right or wrong and most of the time by
the way they're not most if there's an
agenda that means that it's not pure
facts
and this is why you're making your kids
read many people are saying the fact
that they watch a starry coffee said i
watch the social development on netflix
it's really awesome and eye opening
kai did you put the link below for
people to get it just put in the comment
section so they can get it
uh uh but we're coming to the end of it
uh here we have two topics to touch on
we can touch up on
uh supreme court nominee amy coney
barrett or we can touch upon
ballot harvesting project veritas with
ilhan omar which one do you want to
touch on pick it
ladies uh let's let's do scotus let's do
skoda tell us about scottish are you
confident with
the nominee that trump has chosen amy
coney barrett
i think that
i think that what he did with choosing
her
is brilliant
because i have only read opinions from
people on the left about her
only because you can you can read you
can
you can have you can have people
validate your thinking
all day and on sundays so i only read
pieces from people
i read one from from somebody who
clerked with her when she was at the
supreme court
with scalia and he basically said
that another woman who's now the dean of
stanford law school
and her were the most accomplished
brilliant
jurists of that class
and he said i don't agree with 99
percent of her views
but you cannot take away the brilliance
of her mind
and her work ethic and her understanding
of the law and you know it was it was
interesting because
if you go back to kavanaugh
to the kavanaugh hearings which were
just a circus
people with agendas again and you see a
speech by susan collins
republican maine she gave a speech
that i made my 16 year old read the
speech from the beginning to the end
and she said i did my job as a senator
i went and met with him i went and read
through his cases
and his decisions and this whole thing
what saying he's you know some
right-wing crack job
look at his work look at his body of
work you are wrong and she's saying this
to the senate
this witch hunt is inappropriate for
what we're supposed to be doing we're
supposed to be deciding whether or not
this person is a jurist and capable of
being
on the supreme court and so
if nothing else whether it's trump or
his advisors somebody learned a lesson
from that
and they got somebody who is bulletproof
what are your do you think she'll i mean
we're 31 days out 33 from an election 33
33 days out do you think that there's
gonna a vote will be held
i if there are no skeletons in her
closet and it does not seem like there
are
then there's no reason that there would
be
that there wouldn't be an expedited vote
now the risk is
the risk is the constitution does not
cap the number
of justices at 9. the cap in the
constitution is 15.
and that's why during the debate a few
nights ago you kept hearing
trump press biden on will you stack the
court
will you stack the court why won't you
give your list of potential nominees
that's what he's talking about believe
it or not he's read that
that particular portion of the
constitution because i don't think our
president's read most of it
but he understands that element that if
if if the senate is taken by the
democrats
they can come in and increase the size
of the court to 15
such that the court would only be quote
unquote stacked
and right leaning for a short period of
time when's the last time it was more
than nine
never yeah but it could go to fifty fdr
it's never been more than nine but
that's the
it started off as six okay that was back
in
back in the 1800s and then it shifted
over to nine
but again the cap in the constitution is
15.
so why has it never been over nine it's
well it's
it seems like when things become habit
they become habitual
and that was just what it was and how it
stayed and you've always had
a balance um fdr threatened
when he was in office to stack the bench
and to increase the number
because if you're at the bench fdr had a
lot of a lot of his own energy
anyways this is a pivotal time in u.s
history
and we should be paying very close to
what happens now
but also whether or not we're going to
see
the constitution itself by our
politicians
be used legally what about the whole
merrick garlic
uh merrick garland argument meaning they
nominate them it was ten months out now
it's
60 days out they they're not they
nominate amy comey barrett like
again this was this was unseemly
it was arguably the wrong thing to do
but that has never stopped our president
and or mcconnell or mcconnell
and when the shoe was on the other foot
the votes weren't there
so they were able to push back right now
they've got the vote
they've got the ammunition so they can
push it forward here's the question for
you who does this help
is this helping trump's re-election
chances or is this helping by of course
this helps
look if this thing you can you can
count ballots in wisconsin up until
november the 9th
there are there are more than 250 open
lawsuits right now
regarding the election going on
throughout the country
biden's got his army of lawyers trump's
got his army of lawyers they're all
fighting these cases
if if it's going to be thanksgiving
possibly
or maybe into the into december before
we have
a decision if there is a chance that the
supreme court
as was the case with bush is going to
decide the election
then it's really what's happening with
the supreme court is way more important
than
anything else if it's going to go to the
highest court in the land
why do you think it would help biden in
this case no
you asked the question i'm saying why
would i don't oh why would it yeah why
would it
like why we why'd that even why would it
help is the people that are so worried
about roe versus wait if there's ever a
time for you to come out and
show up this is it you know if you
really want to fight for that like you
have to realize hey
the campaign on the left should be we
have to win house we have to so let's
just say he gets the supreme court
the campaign's got to be if we win house
if we have senate and we have presidency
then we can increase the 9 to 11 and we
can put in two no two new supreme court
that's exactly right
we can so the campaign's got to change
from that angle
so i think this is an opening for them
to campaign better and sell it better
there's
many opportunities to use this as a way
to market and help themselves
if biden came out and started to outline
who was going to be in his cabinet
you know he could get people's attention
because everybody knows that it's not
going to be just that one man
i mean that much is known shout out to
the two
twenty seven hundred people that are
watching right now also sarfina who just
gave ten dollars and we've had a few
other people that'll give twenty or
thirty dollars shout out to all of you
guys by the way
um since we're wrapping up here there's
a couple things i do wanna do if you're
enjoying this put a thumbs up and
subscribe and click the alert button so
you're notified i believe
next tuesday i believe next tuesday
we're gonna have a special guest with us
as well
you will know who that guest is next
tuesday is gonna be a special one
don't miss that one but i got a special
gift for you you know
oh adam and i were talking a couple
weeks ago and you were telling me that
joe kick is
is not one of the best passers of all
time you said
sabonis is the greatest big man pastor
of all time
i said john bonus from the portland
trailers and
i went and pulled up the stats and
sabonis was averaging two assists again
and he's one of the greatest so since
you're such a big fan
i got his jersey i said
i got a sabotage
uh by the way somebody said uh danielle
they follow you on twitter they would
like to
have you consider opening your own
facebook fan page
and being more active because these
videos can go viral if you don't have
one so some people want to see you
having a
she will consider it and if she does
maybe on the next time she comes back as
a guest on a podcast
she'll announce it so just write that
down you can talk to the team so having
said that folks
we got two big announcements we'll be
making on the next podcast on tuesday
two massive announcements that i can't
wait to make
next i'm hoping we'll be ready to make
the announcements but i think next
tuesday we're going to make two big
announcements for you again if you
haven't subscribed
do so click that's a thumbs up button
uh sauce good show today danielle thank
you for being back and being a guest on
the first podcast here together
guys take care goodbye goodbye goodbye
bye
you